[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tbs's game 4 coverage from la begins
tonight at 7 30 eastern 4 30 p.m pacific
as we welcome in the great bob costas
bob how would you answer that question
you know i thought that each of your
compatriots had an excellent point and i
do believe given the trend that we're
now observing that it is inevitable that
there will be some sort of electronic
balls and strikes within our lifetime
if i live another x number of years
but yet as was pointed out there is a
rich tapestry to the game dan and i
appreciate all of those nuances the
little subtleties of a catcher framing a
pitch to make a borderline ball appear
to be a strike a pitcher working the
zone figuring out what that particular
plate umpire has as his strike zone that
day can i go an inch further off either
corner and so yes while it is inevitable
it will be a blow to the game and to its
connection to generational history
that's my answer dan because that's what
your guys want my answer to be
but i wonder though bob we have the
technology but but we want the umpires
to get every other call right but when
it comes to the strike zone we're sort
of okay with it being loosely
interpreted why you know like yesterday
for example it looked like
it looked like
walker bueller had jack peterson with
strike three
the replay clearly showed the ball had
the corner
it was an o2 pitch would have been
strike three the outback continued he
got a base hit it was part of a scoring
inning
for the braves
you're right we want everything down to
the micro millimeter
in every other call where
replay is allowed
it's not allowed by the way on check
swings and we saw how that happened the
last pitch of the game in game five in
the division series between the giants
and the dodgers i guess the resistance
with uh
with balls and strikes is
whether or not they really believe
that electronic strike zone is
infallible um and there are some
arguments about the depth of the strike
zone and whether we can exactly get a
guy's stance what if the guy's stance
changes he goes into more of a crouch
he's whatever the case may be uh the
break of the pitch can technology
perfectly capture that to where okay the
plate umpire is 98
accurate but can the and i'm making that
figure up but let's say that's the
figure 98
accurate uh and electronically if we're
only 99 accurate
is that worth it um and i'm not so sure
that i'm as up as i should be on all the
aspects of this uh to be able to say
that they've gotten it to the point
where an electronic balls and strikes
approach will be infallible
what was the most infallible
if it's infallible it's inevitable
what was the mood like prior to cody
bellinger's home run last night
dodger stadium was about as quiet as 50
000 people can be
you heard murmurs rather than cheers a
few brave souls tried to get a let's go
dodgers chant going
uh and it went nowhere
when will smith and aj pollock got hits
and brought
bellinger to the plate then the place
came alive and when he connected
it changed from a morgan to a mad house
just like that
and i what is it about bellinger you
know like it used to be the mendoza line
was the
embarrassing number at 200. he's back
165 during the season but
seventh inning on in the postseason he's
become a different hitter what what has
gotten into that
well you know he's he's had excellent
regular seasons previously and this
season there was a combination of things
injuries and then he couldn't get
untracked
and now i guess he's just feeling it
what was really interesting uh the home
run yesterday that he hit off luke
jackson
that pitch was up and usually the book
with bellinger is if you're going to
miss miss up because he has that extreme
uppercut
swing and he'll just lash a low pitch
out of the park and somehow he got on
top of a pitch that probably was above
the strike zone
and hit it 400 feet
what's the biggest story line so far the
postseason
well i think one of them would be
if the braves who are still up despite
the fact that the momentum seems to have
changed the braves are up two games to
one uh the biggest storyline could be
that
if we ever didn't realize it we realize
it now
this is a tournament
162 games to get there but already the
team that won the most 107 is out
didn't even get to one step from the
world series out
close series with the dodgers but out
the dodgers 106. they could very well be
out
the braves let's say could make it to
the world series 88 wins was the fewest
for any division winner and the red sox
could very well as a team that barely
qualified as a wild card the red sox
could very well be their opponent
the old saying in sports it's not so
much who you play it's when you play
them
it's a long season uh the way pitching
staffs are used now with openers and uh
starters being applauded for giving you
four solid innings it's just a different
game than it used to be and more so than
ever especially with two wild cards and
maybe in the future there'll be more
wild cards than that the postseason is
just a roll of the dice how do you think
history is going to treat jose altuve
the longer his career goes and the
better he performs
it's a good question but the longer his
career goes the better he performs the
further it is in the rearview mirror
i think on balance
it will treat him kindly
carlos correa said recently
that jose
was somebody who did not want to hear
the banging on the trash can
that he did not benefit uh from that
but then there's the image of him coming
around third after hitting that series
winning homer offer all this chapman and
he appears to be clutching his jersey
and he's yelling at his teammates don't
rip my jersey off
and that led to speculation that there
was some kind of wire on him um so if
carlos is correct maybe altuve was
an innocent spectator
who just didn't spill the beans because
of the code of omerta but
if the thing about wearing a wire is
true and if we ever get a definitive
answer to that that could change the
picture but i think that generally
speaking people's memories outside of
those who feel that they were directly
burned by the astros dodgers fans from
2017 whatever i think most will be
forgiving because he's a terrific player
and from all indications he seems to be
a very nice guy yeah but shoeless joe
jackson maintained he never took any
money and he hit 375
but
you know what he's uh he's paid the
prices well
obviously
barred from the hall of fame never going
to get in
yeah you know he was actually people
don't realize this he was actually on
the ballot in the early days of the hall
of fame he was on the ballot never got
enough support he died in 1950
he was still technically eligible for
veterans committees until in 1991
two years after pete rose was banned by
bart jamadi the board of directors of
the hall of fame put in a rule that said
anybody who's on the permanently
ineligible list is not eligible for the
ballot and that was obviously aimed
directly at pete rose since at that
point uh joe jackson had been dead for
more than 40 years
you know and
here's just an aside uh i'm not a
moralist on this i don't know if i've
talked with you about this before dan
but my dad was an inveterate gambler
of the guys and dolls damon runyon
school he bet with guys named blinky and
three finger who undoubtedly were
connected to the mob
and this is in the 1960s uh and very
often the mortgage wrote on whether he
would win his bets or or lose his bet so
i'm not being a moralist about this but
within the last decade every
commissioner of baseball has testified
before congress that legalized gambling
would be the end of sports as we know it
would be the worst thing that could ever
happen and now there's so much money
available they can't turn their backs on
it and not only do they embrace it
they promote it
and yet pete rose who's in his 80s
and who
you wouldn't want to defend in every
respect as a person i'm not going to
defend everything he did in baseball or
outside baseball
he never did anything so far as the
evidence we have never did anything that
undermined the integrity of the
competition
as much as those who are still in the
game that have been suspended but have
returned those who were on the hall of
fame ballot whether they get elected or
not
here he is on the outside looking in
how can this be made any more absurd
what would the harm be if pete rose went
on the hall of fame ballot or was
eligible before a veterans committee and
if he's on the ballot the clock should
start from zero he was never on the
clock so you should get 10 years on that
ballot if you want to do it that way or
make him given his age immediately
eligible for veterans committee
considerations and if people want to
hold the gambling against him in light
of all the present realities in light of
all the comparisons to other people
within baseball and their misdeeds let
them do it but at least let them be
considered well i just wonder and and i
i've talked to the previous commissioner
about this of further evidence that pete
bet when he was playing which i believe
he was betting when he was playing and
we know that he bet when he was managing
and he said well
and years ago he told uh told me and
keith oberman
i bet on my team to win
well you can manipulate the lineup to
help you win
um
and i don't can you separate pete as the
manager betting on baseball with just
pete as the player and maybe we don't
have as much
evidence there that like could i put him
in the hall of fame because he was a
hall of fame player
and you know punish him by keeping him
out of baseball because of what he did
as a manager is it fair to split him up
like that
well
in the big picture i think you can
you can temper justice with mercy
people who've committed heinous crimes
and i realize there's an apple apples
and oranges aspect here but people who
have committed heinous crimes get
paroled in less time than this
and we know that if pete rose lives to
be a hundred
in the first paragraph of his obituary
will be
the fact that he bet on baseball and was
banned for baseball from baseball
because of it the price that he has paid
in his life and in his legacy is
enormous
so you know you could take that into
account
i would think by the way i asked rob
manford that question about five years
ago is there anything
in
that baseball has on pete rose that the
public does not know about you don't
even have to specify it but is there
something beyond the public
understanding that leads baseball to say
to say no this is a non-starter and his
answer to that was no
yeah
our reasons are out there we know what
our reasons are if i gave you one vote
pete rose roger clemens barry bonds
you know dan you have such good
questions um
you know i i've said this before and
said it to you
some people with regard to barry bonds
let's say
tom verducci is one i have great respect
for tom he says i don't care if you took
steroids the last year of your career
and you already had a record number of
home runs if you ever did it once that's
it as far as i'm concerned
my position is a little bit more lenient
than that
when you talk about clemens and
especially bonds you're talking about
people who are on the short list of the
greatest of the great if you shrunk the
hall of fame by 80 or 90 percent
on their performing merits they'd still
be in the hall of fame so
you know i could see voting for all of
those guys
especially because of
the price they have paid to their
reputations the amount of time
that they have waited
uh
i'd probably go
i'd probably actually go rose bonds
clemens in that order rose bonds clemens
yeah
yeah
but with with ambivalence with
ambivalence you know in the case of
bonds it's a terrible shame
barry bonds
is a very intelligent guy and his
baseball iq is at an einstein level and
on his natural merits he'd be in the
discussion of the dozen or so greatest
all-around non-pitchers who ever played
and think how much better his legacy
would be outside san francisco where
they love him seemingly unconditionally
but think how much better his legacy
would be if he had hit 575 career home
runs you know hit 295 lifetime won all
the gold gloves had all the great
seasons you know he'd be in the hall of
fame um and he'd be
he'd be close to universally respected
and admired and when barry bonds wants
to sit with someone and talk with them
he's so engaging he has that beautiful
smile
people who know him well talk about his
charitable acts and how uh and how
engaging he can be but he did play a
good portion of his career with a chip
on his shoulder because of the
mistreatment that his dad had received
and because of some of what he saw uh
willie mays go through earlier in his
career although now willie is is beloved
by everyone so there was a chip on his
shoulder and a lot of that was projected
to the media but so what had he never
used steroids had he never turned
baseball into a video game and distorted
the competition all of that would have
been a mere footnote and he'd now be
at the top of the hall of fame pyramid
it's a shame i remember asking him about
all of this information that you know he
is you know his baseball iq and i said
do you share this information with your
teammates and he goes no
because one day they could be my
opponent not my teammate oh god
like wow
okay
all right
yeah
wow yeah because
tonight
we're teammates yeah but tomorrow we
might not not during the world series
yeah i'm telling you trying to win the
world series uh well have fun tonight
bob it's great to talk to you and uh
thanks for joining us as always
thank you dan take care that's bob
costas uh he'll be joined by pedro
martinez jimmy rollins curtis granderson